take a minute i know you do with senator
tillis to speak directly
to the legitimate concerns that alaska
veterans have raised
who feel as though military experience
is the
prerequisite for the va secretary to
understand
and have a baseline understanding of
their needs their service their
experience so
if you can address all those i'd
appreciate it thank you senator
and uh i appreciate um the
question and i appreciate the concern
at the heart of uh the question
about uh who's best
prepared to be va secretary
i'm not a gunnery sergeant but i'm a
fighter and i'm relentless
anybody who's worked with me knows that
two i know how the government works
and importantly i know when and how
it doesn't work and
i will fight relentlessly
to ensure that it works for our vets so
i think my constituents my veterans
their families they want to know
will you have their back
i've spent the last 20 years involved in
decisions about
when and where as a staff person i'm not
going to overstate my role but as a
staff person when
and where our
men and women go to fight and i've
gone and seen and met and witnessed what
they're doing
and i've gone to visit them when they're
injured here at home
and i have
seen and internalized their excellence
and i know that the
basic requirement of a va secretary is
to have their back
to ensure that i will fight like hell
to take as good a care of them as
they've taken of us
so in the immortal words of cajun bob
you will kick ass and kick ass and take
names on behalf of our veterans
yes sir that's important they need to
know it yes sir
uh i also want to get your commitment
first year of your tenure to get up to
alaska meet with my veterans
see our state see the challenges can i
get your commitment on that you've got
that commitment can i get your
commitment
you know you if confirmed you're going
to run a big bureaucracy
can i get your commitment to kind of do
a vfr
direct with all of us on this committee
when we have issues
we go directly not through the 18 layers
of bureaucracy
to yes you have that commitment let me
ask one final question
um again these were concerns from my
veterans
uh you served in the obama
administration
my first two years in the senate were
the last years of the obama
administration a lot of the issues i was
dealing with
were some of the big va problems
the choice program which in my state the
implementation was an utter
disaster that actually collapsed the
system in alaska
i mean total disaster the
phoenix wait time scandal what did you
learn
from these and do you think
that experience is going to help you
does that is that a liability given your
background
and um can you
assure my veterans that we're not going
to go
back to those days which i don't think
anyone on this committee thinks
we're good days for our veterans we've
made a lot of progress
since that and we've made a lot of
progress back home in alaska
particularly
as it relates to putting together alaska
plan
that got us out of the hole the choice
program put us in
thank you senator
the lifeblood of a well-run
well-functioning organization or agency
is
timely accurate information
that was not the case in phoenix
the lifeblood of a well-run organization
is accountability
accountability happened
in phoenix but it was slow you all have
subsequently
changed the statute to make that easier
and it won't ever happen again
at the end of the day the principle
that will inform my leadership
of the va if i'm confirmed is whether
any decision increases access and
improves outcomes for our vets
that is what we owe the vets that is
what my commitment
to you to the vsos and to them
and to the president
is that i will deliver if confirmed as
secretary
thank you thank you mr chairman thank
you senator sullivan senator joe manchin
iii hallelujah
thank you mr chairman and
congratulations on your lofty position
um first of all mr mcdonald thank you
very much and if i may say dennis we've
known each other for a while
and i'm glad that my colleagues brought
up about you know sometimes they think
we need to be
veterans and i never had the honor and
the pleasure of being able to be a
veteran i wish
i think that's a void in my life i think
back i was an altar boy for 12 years
i was a boy scout for a long time never
made it to the military
and that's something i really think
there's a void and i think it's a
special
opportunity but we know that it takes a
person who cares and has the experience
to do the job
and that's where you come in and i think
dennis that it says everything
let me tell you a little bit of what
you're facing and what i faced in five
years i've been on this committee
i came on this committee and 114th
congress in 2015.
since then they've talked about the wait
time scandals that led to the va
choice act that led to the mission act
which needs a lot of repairs as you know
the veterans unemployment and hiring
after the financial crisis we had more
veterans
unemployed took longer to get them back
employed we had a
you know we started i hire a vet a
campaign all over the country
toxic exposure agent or burn pits i know
you're very much
aware of those and it's that's it's
really wreaking havoc today
the veteran suicide and mental health
that we deal with on a daily basis
veterans homelessness is something that
i can't
comprehend at all how we can have any
veterans okay that we wouldn't have
better
care for the women veterans healthcare
access women think they've been left out
or not a high priority and they're an
intricate part of our military and our
defense today
the hiring backlog over 40 000 vacancies
in the va
veterans affairs i.t infrastructure
delay uh
clarksburg va murders
if anything i've ever ever experienced
in my life
is knowing that we could have veterans
who were murdered
in a veterans hospital and we have eight
confirmed a woman that will be serving
many life sentences over and over and
there might be as many as three more
uh we had sexual we've had uh sexual
abuse just found in another
beckley va hospital uh four veterans we
know of and probably 40 more
over 25 years span
there's a breakdown somewhere sir and
and
we're just going to need someone like
you who can dig into that because to me
it would be vetting we're not vetting
people properly we're not having
strict rules adhere to but more
importantly we passed in 2017
accountability and whistleblower
protection act
we wanted to make sure that we could
basically get rid of the people that
weren't doing their job
i don't think that that's been exercised
much since then
and i'll give you a perfect example the
people that i hold responsible
for the va hospital deaths in clarksburg
have been moved to other places in the
va system
unheard of and i knew way back when this
happened in meeting with them
that someone was either lying to me or
totally incompetent
and now when i found out we brought new
leadership in they were remove somewhere
i can't find
i can't find them and i'd like to know
on that if we could bring that to high
sporty i think
to put to put the credibility back in
the va the care
and the desire for the care that they
deserve
i would ask you one of your first visits
to come to clarksburg va and set down
what your mission would be and i think
sir
that could set the tone for the entire
va system all over the country
it's just unbelievable totally
unbelievable now families
i have families calling me daily then my
father or grandfather
lose their life because someone murdered
them when they were there still not
knowing for sure
these are all the things that we're
dealing with today you can help
ease that pain i think but dennis i look
forward to you
we need someone of your of your ability
more now than ever
and like i said i'm in awe today of
every person i see in uniform
all the people you see out here garden
this great republic of ours
and anybody who has served to give them
the greatest care so
with that i know the challenges are
great if you'd like to comment on any of
that
i know you've probably been following
some of this yeah but i don't know to
what extent on that
well i thank you very much senator and i
have been following it and
and we had a very good conversation
which i appreciated thank you for that
uh
and my my commitment is as as a uh as i
assured you before which is to work in
close consultation
and uh collaboratively with you and with
the rest of the members of the committee
on these questions
i think you're going to find a committee
that's worked and i'm just about
finished
a committee that's worked in a most
bipartisan way i've said this before and
i mean it's all my heart
men and women in uniform are the glue
this country they keep us together
they keep us talking they keep us
finding ways to work together to make
sure that we're taking care
of those who are taking care of us so
you you've got it in your hands now the
cradle
basically of the people who've made the
country what we are today
and we owe it to them so with that being
said you're going to find all the
support
if we don't have a piece of legislation
that allows you to reorganize that
allows you to basically get rid of the
dead wood and people who don't care
my grandmother always said people don't
care how much you know until they know
how much you care
i know how much you care now you have to
show the rest of the world
thank you thank you sir thank you i look
forward to voting for you too
thank you count me in thank you for
being a game coach
you you got it big boy thank you senator
manchin uh remotely we have uh
senator blackburn yeah thank you
uh i appreciate that and uh mr mcdonough
thank you so much for the time this week
it was wonderful to visit with you by
phone let me just
um and i appreciate your commitment
you've talked some about your passion
and that relentless commitment to doing
the job and to public service
so very quickly what would uniquely
qualify you to lead
the va with a budget that is in nearly a
quarter of a trillion dollars and 400
000
employees and it serves 9
million enrolled veterans so kind of
following on to
senator manchin's question what is your
unique qualification
thank you senator uh i
i as you've indicated i am a fighter and
i'm relentless
and that means i will fight to get our
vets back
and i will ensure uh relentlessly
that we the resources
that you've authorized and appropriated
for the committee are invested
wisely and with the veteran at
the center of those investments
i also understand how the government
works
from both ends of pennsylvania avenue
that means
uh demanding excellence that means
enforcing accountability that means
being in close collaboration and
consultation with you and other members
of this committee
to ensure that we're using all the
available power of the u.s government to
get our vets backs
lastly for 20 years now i've been
involved in these decisions about when
and where to send our men and women to
war
not as a decider i'm not trying to
overstate my role but as a staff
person i've also
seen the excellence
of our military and i've seen
the challenges of long deployments
and i've seen the sacrifices
but i've seen the resilience
and there is no higher calling
than to be able to use my skills and my
experience
to repay and to ensure that we live up
to the promises
we've made to our vets let let me jump
in
there because uh senator moran
and others have talked about community
care and you and i talked a little bit
about this you've got choice you've got
mission
we've got as part of repaying these
veterans
many that want to get care in their
communities you talked about the right
balance of care and
i would like for you to bring just a
little bit of clarity
uh to that what do you see is the right
balance of care
and would you commit that
you're not going to roll back on on
standards
and reverse the intent
of a veteran-centric care
and addressing the whole health of the
veteran
thank you senator the community care
will continue to be a
fundamental way that the department
provides care
to our veterans one two
the statute is clear on this it says
that
best medical outcome for the veteran
is the objective and that will continue
to be
my priority if confirmed as secretary
third every decision i make as secretary
will come back to this principle which
is
is it increasing access for veterans and
is it improving outcomes for veterans
if the answer to those questions are no
then we won't do it
okay well and you and i discussed
the health records the electronic health
records and others have brought that up
today
and you know my frustration with a four
billion dollar i.t budget
and they can't seem to get it right and
indeed senator tester
and i had legislation this year that
would have improved the management
of that and for the record we're about
out of time i'll send you
uh qfr on the management of those
programs and then
you and i also discussed purchasing and
for the record i will send you
a question uh delving a little bit more
into that purchasing but
thank you for the time today thank you
for your commitment
and mr chairman i'll send the time back
to you
thank you senator blackberry next we
have remotely senator cinema
thank you mr chairman i appreciate mr
mcdonough joining us today
my office is increasingly hearing from
arizona veterans
asking for clarification on how to
receive the code vaccine from the va
and when they'll be able to receive it
my staff has been working locally to
make sure information is getting out to
the community
and this highlights the importance of
having senate confirmed leadership at
the department of veterans affairs as
quickly as possible
i've introduced with senator tillis the
insuring survivor benefits during
coveted legislation
to address concerns that survivors of
veterans who died from coping may not be
granted their earned benefits
if the death certificate only identifies
cova-19
as a cause of death without considering
the impact of other service connected
illnesses
if confirmed will you work with me to
ensure that processes are in place to
address these concerns
yes senator i will thank you over the
last year
my office has worked at the va american
legion and phillips north america to
bring an atlas site to arizona
we hope to provide more details about
that site in the coming weeks
the atlas or the accessing telehealth
through local area stations program
is part of va's anywhere to anywhere
telehealth initiative
to bring a va telehealth access point to
underserved communities
in arizona there may be many rural and
tribal communities
that could benefit from this and other
telehealth initiatives
if confirmed will you continue to work
with our office to expand telehealth
opportunities
to rural and tribal communities yes i
will
as we consider expansion we have to
acknowledge the challenges of access to
broadband in these communities
as the va continues to expand its
telehealth initiatives
what role do you feel the va should play
in addressing broadband access but
thanks senator i think that the va has a
key role to play
in coordinating with other federal
agencies
uh and with the fcc to ensure that the
kinds of
access questions that va can
lead on including on telehealth can be
expanded by
better broadband access more universally
available so
i think there's a critical role to play
within the interagency
and that's if confirmed would be
precisely what i intend to do
thank you you know in arizona the navajo
nation has been hit particularly hard by
covet
the cdc notes that native americans are
at a disproportionate risk for
complications from covet
due to health and socioeconomic
disparities in these communities
they also experience other inequities
such as high instances of homelessness
and challenges accessing clean drinking
water and sanitation
if confirmed what steps will you take to
ensure the va's best serving native
american veterans
this uh this would be a fundamental
priority
uh consistent with uh the president's
state of priorities on
equity and state uh consistent with
what i have said throughout the day
today which is how are we increasing
access and improving outcomes for all
vets
and third consistent with the direction
to me from the president
to ensure that va is welcoming of
all veterans uh including obviously
uh navajo and other native american
veterans
so there's a fundamental role for us for
the va to play there and
if confirmed i would intend to play that
role
i appreciate that thank you information
technology modernization has been and
continues to be a central focus for the
va if confirmed you'll be responsible
for overseeing these major modernization
efforts
as cyber security threats continue to
increase across the u.s
what steps will you take to ensure the
va is equipped to protect against cyber
threats
and is practicing good cyber hygiene
thank you senator obviously cyber uh the
the range of cyber threats that we
confront uh as a country is only growing
having cyber security cyber hygiene
front and center
not only for the major programmatic uh
efforts at the department but also for
individual individuals in the workforce
at the department will
have to be a fundamental priority for
the next secretary
and if that's me i would intend to make
that cyber security a key
uh priority thanks you know the va still
has a number of legacy systems it's
supporting
these can not only be costly but also
generally do not follow
or accommodate today's security best
practices
what would be your approach to
addressing legacy systems if confirmed
as va secretary
thank you senator obviously there has to
be a fundamental focus on
cyber security and cyber hygiene across
uh
the enterprise one and then two is
effectively
performing on the modernization efforts
will allow
va to not only increase security
and increase performance and outcomes
for vets
but will also re reduce costs over time
of these legacy systems
so executing on the modernization has to
be a key priority
and i i see that my time has expired um
with your indulgence mr chair i will um
submit the rest of my questions for our
nominee and i want to thank him for
joining us here today
uh thank you senator cinema and in that
regard the questions need to be in by
tomorrow at 5 00 pm
last but certainly not least and i've
been in your position before senator
kramer senator cramer
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
mcdonough and i don't mind frankly
it means that i don't have to ask dennis
about rural veterans native american
veterans
telehealth coven 19 mission act or
community care network so we can
we can get right down to the business of
uh clemens stadium johnny's football
and jay christensen stadium versus the
cobbers how about that i'd like that
all right well we'll get to that on your
way to alaska when you stopped
in fargo okay but
you and i did have a wonderful
discussion i want to tell you how much i
appreciated
the meeting we had earlier this week we
did drill down on a number of these
issues as well as
one of my um most important issues
that's probably a little more unique to
me and that is of course the use of
alternative forms of of therapies
treatments
uh particularly hyperbaric oxygen
treatment
and um the reason i'm such a
proponent of hyperbaric oxygen treatment
for uh
and therapies for veterans is because
i've seen it work so well
a number of veterans that i know have
have
really had their lives changed and in
some cases saved
by this important therapy as well as
others who've had
injuries that come from sports
particularly head trauma
uh traumatic brain injuries and um
and so so i'm i am a strong proponent of
it
and wants to know and i by the way very
much appreciated your
dialogue with um with senator moran
because he was getting to the heart of
an issue that i think a lot of us
as you could probably tell are
challenged by and that is just how large
the bureaucracy is and how difficult it
can
be to maneuver it and how often we'll
actually
pass legislation that's signed into law
only to have it sort of either slow
walked or
whether intentionally or unintentionally
i happen to believe that most of the
time it's
it's with good intentions but um
but with regard to hbot i was able to
get language
in the john scott legislation that
you're very familiar with
um that would authorize the secretary of
the va
to enter into public-private
partnerships to research the
effectiveness of hyperbaric oxygen
therapy
and it would require and i stress
require the va to use an objective test
to measure the effectiveness
of hyperbaric oxygen therapy and
it would commission a comprehensive
review and study of hbot
both within the va and i think
importantly outside with outside
organizations as well because there's
just a lot of experience out there that
to this point hasn't been brought in my
view into a
good peer-reviewed objective
study but it would be completed with a
recommendation then from the va about
the effectiveness of hbot
i i stress that because that is language
and bill that makes it law
and and i believe there are as i said
real benefits
to this innovative therapy and by the
way other innovative therapies and
i think you and i talked about the
important role the va has played
leadership role it's played in some of
very effective alternatives um to to a
traditional medicine or in addition to
traditional medicine but i really want
to just i guess again
uh thank you for listening um and get
a reaffirmation of your commitment to
fulfill both that
the letter of that law and then the
spirit of it
and uh and then accept my invitation to
fargo on your way to alaska to see dan
sullivan
uh anytime i can go to fargo i'll take
it one two is
uh i'll be uh happy to recommit to
making sure that we dig into the
into the analysis of the therapy
consistent with
uh the intent and the statute and
consistent with
getting to the brass tack here to find
out uh what's the best way and best uh
vehicles to deliver
that kind of care to our vets that
they've earned i appreciate that i've
written down a number of the things
you've said in quotes
um i won't repeat all of them but i but
one thing you've said a couple of times
in response to the question about
your your cred if you will your street
cred for this job and i love that when
you say i know how government works
i think that's oftentimes a mis or under
appreciated
skill set and gift and um
an experience so i believe you when you
say that
you have every reason to know how
government works as you said you've seen
it from both ends of
pennsylvania avenue and count me as a
an affirmative vote thank you and
someone who looks forward to working
with you
once you are confirmed thank god i yield
the rest of my time this year thank you
thank you
yeah thank you senator kramer before i
have my closing marks i will turn it
over to the ranking member
senator moran chairman tester
thank you very much uh it was tolerable
to have you in the chair today
and uh it's not exactly what i wanted
but
it's not a bad deal either so thank you
for
working with me and my colleagues on
this side of the aisle as we commit to
do to you and your colleagues
and mr mcdonough before i ask you a
question i wanted to point out to
the committee uh that we have a new
staff director
uh now on the minority side uh who came
from the house minority side but was
in the both the minority and majority
staff world
uh in the senate uh and is returning now
to the senate this is his first
meeting since uh his arrival and john
towers is behind me uh and uh we
look forward to having him and his help
and we make him available to you mr
mcdonough should you be confirmed
thank you um
mr mcdonough would you commit to me that
you're a fan of the chiefs
uh senator moran i um
i'm a big fan of patrick mahomes
i'm but i'm a vikings fan and i i hate
to admit
that i kind of i'm kind of old school
that way so
well you could have answered the
question in a worse way
so mr mcdonough i thank you for your
interest
in serving as the secretary of the
department of veterans affairs
i thank you for your testimony today
i just wanted you to know based upon
what you have said
and what i have learned about you that i
will vote for your confirmation thank
you and i will ask my republican
colleagues to do the same
and i look forward to working with you
and your commitment is evident to me
and um i think we can accomplish a lot
on behalf of those who served our nation
working together
so uh best wishes uh to you and your
family and i thank them
i know your wife in particular is
involved in veterans services
and i would express my gratitude as i
did personally to her but here publicly
for her efforts uh and so as a family uh
we wish uh
you all well in this new endeavor thank
you very much i'm grateful for your
service thank you
thank you so much senator uh senator
moran
uh uh mr mcdonough i i don't know if
if moran had that question that he asked
you and knew that
the real impact of it but not only is
jerry moran a cheese fan but
my committee director is also
a chiefs fan so um you know i mean
i guess it doesn't matter if you're a
vikings fan as long as you root for the
chiefs in the super bowl
that's all okay i also want to welcome
john towers
john is somebody that both jerry and i
had the opportunity to work with
when he was in the house and and as you
well know
uh dennis often times the relationship
between the principles
is important but the relationship
between the staff is more important
you're here
and uh so i want to welcome you on board
john
um and i also want to thank your wife
and your family that have set
attentively behind you
uh nodding their heads and paying
attention and i can't see their eyes so
i don't think they nodded off
very often anyway but but the truth is
is we all know that the
the the power and the ability for any of
us to serve
in any of these positions whether it's
elected or staff
really relies with the family and how
important they are to
to our ability to do our job and and i
want to thank our committee today for
their their thoughtful questions and uh
and their um
their belief and and and the way they
put across the fact that
veterans are number one in this
committee and that's that's why we work
on this committee uh so well
you know i looked at the the fbi report
uh the day before yesterday and i think
senator moran is going to do it tomorrow
and uh i don't think i'm out of school
by saying that it was
pretty darn stellar in fact i told the
lady that brought it in i would have to
pay a lot of money to get this many
recommendations of what a fine fellow
i am and so you are a highly qualified
candidate and i believe that you will
work with this committee to ensure that
we keep the promises to the to the men
and women who have served
uh their country and and their families
too by the way
and uh senator moran visited and we have
an agreement that we plan to meet again
on tuesday to vote on
dennis mcdonough's nomination to be
secretary of the veterans affairs
as well as the committee rules in the
budget and
and that's what we're going to do i
think the fact that you had not met with
senator tillis or
senator sanders yet and the fact that
the ranking member had not seen the fbi
report
requires us to do it then otherwise i
would have tried to move it up but i'm
not going to based on that
i would ask as i pointed out to senator
cinema that any post hearing questions
be sent to the clerk
by tomorrow at 5 pm and
and then we will need those responses
back from you before we vote on tuesday
with that once again i want to thank you
and your family for being here always a
pleasure to work with senator moran
this hearing is adjourned thank you i
haven't thought about seeing you know
okay